have you considered a career in
professional fighting i saw you did a
self-defense class you did a jiu jitsu
did you see the ten-year-old kid who
throwing her through her yes and
apparently i could have broken a leg but
it's actually funny like chess boxing is
a thing and i have been doing a lot of
boxing like
i physical activity is like honestly one
of my favorite things to do and i have
been testing it out on content and we
have a creative friend who's hosting a
chess boxing tournament but there's no
woman who's could match me unfortunately
because all the opponents are male
and i can't fight a guy
how does chess boxing work so you do a
round of chess and round of boxing and
we actually did a training camp for it
before and of course like after you go
into the ring is this real this
seriously actually yeah we went to the
london chess boxing club and like after
you've seen like videos i thought it was
something you did in russia or something
no it's a real sport yeah
yeah no it's very cool but after you get
really tired you're more likely to make
a mistake
or something yeah there's probably good
strategies like what do you want to
because some of it is a cardio thing do
you want to work on your chest they do
both it's very fun
but yeah from a content perspective i'm
sure there's a lot of people that like
and would love it very entertaining
would love to see
yeah i don't want to see andrea getting
hit that would be i would love to oh she
doesn't get hit but i wouldn't get it
our roommate would fought in a fight and
she did end up winning but seeing her
get hit i thought i was going to throw i
just think it was so cool she had no
experience in boxing whatsoever and then
coming from someone in the content world
where you start like waking up six days
a week at six a.m and he's training
every day like you know like a real
professional athlete i think like it's
such a unique experience and also like a
really test of how much you can really
commit to this and progress
you